the second year of the grand chest or
started off with a bang first it was a
trip to gay Paree as the top chest minds
in the world descended on the majestic
city of light to show off their
brilliant play in blitz and wrap in
while many of the players were trying to
gain their footing the competition
quickly turned into a two horse race
between world champion magnus carlsen
and blood specialist Akari Nakamura in
the end it was the American who showed
off his lightning-fast skills to clinch
the event with two rounds to spare and
to establish himself as the early tour
leader less than a week later the
players were off to leuven belgium for
the second leg of the tour where they
were joined by a five-time world
champion Viswanathan Anand who played a
brilliant game in round one to destroy
magazine bashe lagrave and send a
message that he would be a force to be
reckoned with the intense pressure
affected all the players from the start
as magnus carlsen forfeited on time in a
winning position and nakamura
inexplicably lost his first three games
in a row to head to the bottom of the
tournament table american wesley so
proved unbeatable in the first two days
of rapid while Levon Aronian and vishy
anand played well to leave the
leaderboard jumbled going into the final
day but in the end it was Magnus the
magnificent who easily dominated his
rivals winning game after game to win
the title and leave no doubt why he is
indeed the best chess player on the
planet
it's all on to st. Louis for the fourth
edition of the sink filled [ __ ] the best
chess players in the world return to the
capital of chess in the United States
for the third leg of the grand chest
tour
you